when we were asked to contribute to the
decoration of the art world the juices
lips use we thought about this work of
the artist pistoletto because we thought
that it could represent well enough the
spirit of Italy nowadays the third
paradise is a fantastic opera that at
the same time provides the sense of what
we used to be the first paradise were
the natural the men the beginning of
mankind fully in invaded in nature the
second paradise is the artificial world
but has become the world in the enduring
this year's and the third iodized one
that we're all hoping for is how to
merge the two of these two dimension the
natural dimension with your differential
with the one of the world and it is a
message of hope and of openness towards
the present and this is exactly what the
Italy is trying to do today provide a
new hope for Europa for this new cycle
this new institutional cycle that is
starting nowadays the other aspect that
we are trying to illustrate here induces
lips user is an important element of
Italian creativity DC design and we have
done in two ways first having a exposing
a number of objects that have been
winning the golden compass in the past
years that are almost iconic in their
significance like for example later
vintage where the typewriter produced by
olivetti or the portable TV set of bri
on Vega but also the number of objects
that are just here in the back of this
entrance that are the representation of
the modern in contemporary design so a
number of objects that have been
a word it will be a golden compass this
year and you will find objects that I
would say are typically for an award
like a table or a lamp but also others
that are much less typical than that
like for example a manhole that you can
find in the street and its various a
particularly beautiful but also very
practical in the way it is design or a
tractor which is always the link will be
with the activity of people at the same
time we are also trying to give a sense
of what the creativity and the design is
in other sectors like in the area of
furniture that is always a part of the
story of the illustration of our design
of our contemporaries and in Italy